[Laughter]
and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win we are back ah big week in
sports Espace once again raiders
first-half champs we did it again three
you know just keep rock joining me is
everybody's favorite comic in the world
Jason Tebow everybody everyone can suck
me off okay hello Canada my coffee okay
and also joining us is everybody's
favorite Christian comic he's doing a
young Christian comedy tour of Europe
Jason Ross everybody yeah thank you
Hey Gani dates out the gates
I got a few hey if anybody's going to
the Rams Vikings game come to our
tailgating party a bunch of people you
know from all things comedy will be
there
rent is easy Dennis and oniel team
everybody's gonna be there so if you're
going to be at the Rams game Thursday
come find us I'm also going to be at the
Queen Mary Dairy Queen selling ice cream
for the vets of the Civil War you can
also find me on the 4th movement of
Taurus I'm going to be emceeing at the
March of Dimes bags at in Long Beach
where I'll be selling pot to sick
children all things comedy fest the 25th
20 the 28th in October come see us in
Phoenix and the 6th of October at
Sycamore tavern we are going to be doing
our fight companion for the big UFC
McGregor khabib fight pom get some I
will be sucking anybody off in the
parking lot that says punch drunk you
say the word punch drunk today you're
gonna get I'm gonna get a mouthful of
your Wang that's right it's the punch
drunk UFC 229 viewing party and stand up
past there and suck off and suck a
viewing party and suck on come upstairs
hang out with us as we watch the fights
followed by stand-up comedy by some of
your favorite stand-up comic comedians
hey I wonder if Danish and O'Neal would
like to be a part of that maybe
they would maybe they want their dick
sucks too all right that's actual but
before that October 3rd I am at the Brea
improv it's an evening of Sam Triple E
and his weirdo friends Kate Quigley Mike
Tully the the smash brothers Corrine
Chad and George fries all at the Bray
improv go to Brea calm brea dot improv
calm come hang out and then I also have
October 12th I will be at the Philly
punch line for tinfoil hat comedy night
Eddie Bravo myself go to Philly Punk
shine dot Philly calm or punch line
Philly calm and then October 14th I'm
back in the homeland back in the
homeland of 607 the three one five
please come to the funny bone for
tinfoil hat night with Eddie Bravo on
myself and guess who else will be there
my mother
hanging out hearing about lizard people
so grab those tickets now meet-and-greet
after a lot of discussions joining us
Jason do you have any dates you'd like
to push yeah I sent you a JPEG to post
the dates in your phone is there any way
of putting that on the screen no how
about you tell us it real I'm gonna be
in or customers need Oh joining us to
tastic cocker field david copperfield
give us like a week of dates real quick
I'm in Toronto köppen Copenhagen Denmark
actually I'm gonna be there for re-show
so we're gonna hang out and hold hands
Chris Tania yeah
I'll be there I'm there on the 14th in
Copenhagen I think you're on the 4th
Gothenburg Sweden bunch of dates in
Ontario and I shoot a snuff movie I
leave actually tonight I audition for
that
did you yeah went to producers but they
just I couldn't get enough [ __ ] in my
mouth oh but I'm working on it you know
what they call Teebs at the auditions
the golf bag because you can fit so many
clubs in his ass yeah yeah yeah no weird
yeah they've been calling me that before
I started auditioning but it fits in
perfect it's a huge
it's a weird thing because both ends
smell exactly the same there's a reason
for that
hey Ari what are your dates I'm gonna be
in Phoenix October 27 one day that's it
we're all in Danish doing a lifes to
tame breed of shooter my scream script
from college and you're doing that the
faster where are you doing that County
New York common okay that's I really am
sorry I'm gonna miss that are you gonna
it's not gonna be streamed or anything
yeah okay I really am excited about that
yeah okay how many pages is that script
are you 370 pages no it's not yeah God
God I want to [ __ ] I really am
jealous that I'm not a part of how many
characters are gonna be writing have you
decided what characters who and who's
what yeah we have not we're discussing
it now I think one of them will be
shooter I always pictured me playing
that role but you know in 20 years past
I can't play like college anymore and
are you guys great old-timey hat over
there I didn't know you're gonna do a
soft-shoe number hanging on the wall
there look at that it is there it is
right over there that hat put that on
but you know mine put that on me hello
my darling balls on my chair I like jizz
on my toast ha ha balls my kid like jizz
I might
[Applause]
like jizz on my toes this episode isn't
called chisel my touch will never get
uncommon by the way the new name of the
show is everything okay he does have a
kid I like balls on my chin I like juice
on my toast I bend over backwards
ensnare my own sake I'm Uncle Jack Jack
[Laughter]
go down the basement and get your gun
all right when you guys do this table
read is it going to be like a like a
Mystery Science Theater you're gonna
take time out to do zingers are you just
doing a straight-up table read all right
come on in hey Laurie why is there a kid
waving from that cubby hole behind your
head and put her up there they let the
kid go guys joining us real quick in
studio we got a major event that
punch-drunk has been invited to ladies
if you wanna sit down
ah we punch-drunk is invited to
participate this Thursday night at
Ellie's favorite fight night that's
right Kellyanne take Cage Rage
full-contact girl fights amateurs only
it happens every second Thursday in Van
Nuys and every every last Thursday
downtown which is that that means it's
at the spearmint rhinos James II games
topless sports bar and grill ah who do
we have with me right now
yes yeah - ladies - two of the fighters
now you guys guys introduce yourselves
hi Jason everybody nice to meet you okay
we on ax stilts Taylor she is a Playboy
model reality star and guess what cage
champion undefeated never lost no no
they are you guys aren't fighting each
other are you
who's you know who you're fighting well
I don't fight anymore actually host Cage
Rage so you're going tired you retire
champion
what was your record no no that's a lie
actually um I lost once you did what
happened what was the move that took you
off um geez it was a tough fight it was
Nikki miss she's amazing she's she's
like a semi-pro like Bressler like and
she was way bigger than I was I beat her
in the first I told you I'm six feet I
want to make d1 athletes with you who
didn't see this going this way hilarious
raise your hand if you didn't see this
coming uh and we also have Angele Angele
and she is fighting for the Bell your
are you nervous I'm more excited
are you excited what kind of describe
your combats that your fighting style
I'm crazy
so you got a black belt in crazy so you
just go full-bore Jude any grounded
pound any scissor sisters IDing biting
allowed there's nobody waiting no but
there's not in the cage ground-and-pound
there's I mean kicking pretty much
whatever is there what are the rules of
this fight you guys are in bikinis and
you're fighting yes we're in my clothes
girls wear whatever they kind of want to
wear but bikini
[Laughter]
silence listen to this I have a question
like when I was in like like eighth
grade I grew up a girl and area right
before girls would fight it would be
like 20 minutes of them taking like
weaves off and fingernails is there like
a pre fight we like all [ __ ] you're
gonna give us coming to you now or is it
go right at it it's funny cuz we were
just talking about this because she
broke a nail last time when she fought
and I look that's gotta be hard and I'm
like you can't wear those shits you have
to keep fighting there there was it's
funny we had a girl like at our last
fight downtown that wanted to fight so
bad she literally bit her nails off in
the dressing room and was like let me
fight that so she could come when I hear
that I go listen I know I know that case
yeah
fights like okay man we gotta settle
this in whatever you guys fight it are
you guys ever like we've had a few girls
that like strongly disliked each other
and they took it out in does it ever go
after they like they fight and they so
it's so contentious that like when the
fights over it gets in like almost like
a Diaz brothers you know in a locker
room today does never spill over no not
really like we've had some girls like go
at it and get really really mad and take
off their gloves and they were ready to
street fight uh-huh
but of course we stopped that and it
didn't go any further then right in the
cage like you know to me now what kind
of gloves are you wearing like MMA
clothes or boxing projects MMA ok I'm
all MMA gear we have two head gear two
gloves the mouthpiece the the leg gear
and how long are the rounds forty
minutes feels like it really does not
only 3 1 minute rounds but they
we go Ari thinks he can fight five
five-minute rounds cuz he power walks in
New York City tell him what's like the
fight I think you cannot you don't think
I can fight fine
no absolutely oh wow that's crazy around
you will be so gassed that you're done I
don't think you make it five miles I
don't think I can either it's a lot it's
a lot is there like a fight that
everyone's been like that's the greatest
Caliente cage fight of all time well
I've heard that my fight what Nikki miss
was one of the greatest fights what made
it so happy what was it a rumble the
jungle type thing it was just like a
really really intense fight I actually
ended up with a concussion and that's
why I decided I wasn't fighting anymore
because it kind of after that point I
was down for like two weeks and I was
like oh hell no concussion from strikes
to the head or did you hit your head on
the ground no it was definitely some
hits to the head I think I think what
did it was there was one the first punch
that she threw hit me like straight on
Oh like I felt it I was like oh hell and
I got dizzy for a second and I was like
I'm not giving up and the ref was like
you need to tap out and I'm like oh hell
no let's go
now does does house mom make you guys
sit out for like two weeks if you guys
get a concussion like they do in the NFL
where you can't play if you have
concussion-like symptoms well mom like
sit it down take a knee no I mean we
kind of like you know do you guys ever
take a knee during the US we take a me
during the national anthem national
anthem when they play are you guys
taking me during the national anthem we
don't even do they got a bunch of
wonderful people they got a ton of porn
stars come to these things DJing for an
O and Teddy from power 106 they're gonna
be doing the play-by-play correct and
then mr. P who's an adult star who used
to bang
Alexis Texas he's gonna be there and our
friend Matt Slayer is going to be doing
it's all put together by Cornelius now
afterwards you guys fight your ref your
you gotta go dance after like I can get
a lap dance from the chick who just got
knocked out
I mean nothing hotter than a girl that
can take a punch and also sit on your
[ __ ] can we be honest about this guys if
there's dancers that are fighting
absolutely they might eat when I danced
I would go in I literally would not work
the whole day I'd go in I'd win my match
I put my clothes on and I'd go back home
so I wasn't even working after you
weren't good I do have girls done that
yeah girls girls work after they do some
of them that are there all day they'll
work after they'll go back to giving
their lap dances and it is I mean I've
gotten from a lot of guys oh my god
that's so hot come give me a lot and
they're like dude I'm worn out I'm gonna
have a concussion
of course so uh what's it like being a
dancer now is the what's the industry
like my brother runs a strip bar in
Cleveland you know sometimes you got do
stuff like these fight to get it going
has the has the business changed at all
like girls are more kind of crazy is it
I feel like strip bars were really big
back in the day when girls were like oh
I can't do that and then there were some
girls like I don't give a [ __ ] I'll do
whatever you know and then cell phones
it's killed liven yeah for sure and then
you have webcam and you have all kinds
of stuff nowadays but I mean I don't
dance anymore I've been retired from
just started dancing but I danced for a
while though so I was there to see the
transition of how you know yeah good it
was back in the day to now how it can be
a struggle so you have to like find a
lot of promotional things to do nowadays
and strip clubs like what we do Kali and
say cage is a promotional event and we
do topless karaoke we do amateurs and
pros like we do a whole bunch of
different events too you know just to
keep the club thriving wrong people
right back in the day it was just like
it was just beyond you know good you
know you didn't even need to do a whole
lot of you know different promotions to
get people you do you have a creepiest
customer story like the creepiest guy
who came in like is there something
you're like oh god this guy's a creeper
100% both their stories involve you
they both both their stories involve you
I'm certain I'm sure you don't dance
you're just white you don't dance at all
you just want to punch a [ __ ] in the
face you're trying to what's what's
what's so hard so far have you learned
about dancing where you like me you
don't understand that it's a lot harder
than people think
yeah well for me the hardest thing is
because I'm really honestly I really
don't like being around the weirdos in
the club yeah but you know you gotta
fake it till you make it
you describe what a weirdo look like and
why do I think he's Armenian is that
possible so funny though cuz there that
she said this there's a guy that always
comes in to Van Nuys and he's Armenian
you wearing your Raiders woman's coat
bedazzled ladies edition he's hilarious
though like he would just dance around
and do all kinds of crazy things like
he'll be in his own world you look over
and he's just like gyrating and dancing
and doing all kinds of crazy stuff and
he's always there and then we learned
that he's he's a mortician oh those are
the creepers right creeper if I gets
high on embalming fluid and it's weird
it comes to dames and games do you guys
date white boys you date white boys
asking for my friend yeah about time
it's about time so you just started
dancing what made you start dancing just
cash straight cash I just put yourself
through college
no I just thought it was fine like as
far as dancing doing something different
it's completely different
are you learning the poles what really
gotta move with your go-to move flying
spread eagle I go to Whole Foods
what's that ari when I went to strip
clubs doing you know I all my favorite
movers the dine and dash
I pay you to mount and run I love I just
love great pole work I think you should
be an Olympic sport I'm being honest
that's a good name for a band
look great boy no great pole work yeah
that is and just with the can Angelica
girls face with a teardrop on her face
ari I've breaking news you got any is
ready ready for it we got breaking I
mean okay we got breaking news I have
legitimate some legitimate breaking news
for real yeah definitely for real do you
guys try to date the DJ so you can get
your favorite songs play does anyone do
that
waking news Bill Cosby sentenced to 3 to
10 years maximum security leaving in
handcuffs really ten eighty years old
partially blind three to ten years
leaving in handcuffs from court today
Hillary dad I'll be down to [ __ ] oh man
this is gonna be exciting I'm really I
will be there here's what I've been told
the our good friend what's his name real
Cornelius has offered to have
punch-drunk down during the fights
special seats up on the cage so I'm
gonna be going autistic Johnny's okay me
autistic Johnny and I'm gonna bring five
punch drunk fans with me anyone listen
is in the LA area you want some with me
breaking news I'm gonna bring down and
we're gonna go watch the fights these
guys this guy's going to the NFL game
I'm going to watch the hottest action in
downtown and you're fighting for the
title you're fighting for and what is
your record currently fighting for the
title you're undefeated how many well
how many fudge have you had want to know
want to know now when you fight white
girls are you like oh you're trying to
take my boyfriend and you just beat the
shove I'm even more oh yeah
you're great you're right I'm just
kidding all right ladies thank you so
much for coming on we really appreciate
it
and good luck I would love I think
you're gonna win I believe in you thank
you so much and we'll ah I'll see you
guys on Thursday I will be there you're
the only one girl everyone's coming
you're not coming wait you're he's not
come but me an autistic John here he is
gonna you're gonna miss out I am gonna
miss up but it's area every other
Thursday I'll definitely come yes
can you go get the guy to think okay
Wolf Wolf figure we'll find it we'll
find it I wanna take a picture of T band
picture boom well what's the creepiest
thing a guy ever said to you while
you're dancing I want how much boom boom
boom how much how much is a boom boom
boom I'll give you $20 yeah your boom
booms are great that's great one more
one more come on
boom your white hat can I get a white
okay so you put on a hat - yeah here we
go
everybody's got a hat on there we go
there we go I already put on your hat
but yeah put on your baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
bend over backwards my own sack slipping
[ __ ] and I break my back aunt Arina me
all right why do you have that outside
your hat why do you have the old-timey
hat did you march in some sort of 1940s
parade that we need to know about or
that's your Beach out there the one
piece the Charlie Chaplin yeah you got
the old like though bathing suit that
looks like oh there we go
yeah yeah all right he's gonna go change
his ass Ari's got a new Ari all right
before they leave show me your new belt
these this guy's got the dumbest belt
you've ever seen ari Artie's fighting
for the belt - good luck go get that
strap girl I believe in you I believe in
you don't get punched in the face
this is such a good look for you let me
see that bathing suit bye guys
all right let's see that bathing suit
that looks for you look awesome
I take back everything I said when you
go this is what I wear to the beach now
I get it
I get your beach attire do you take the
king to the beach so you're not gonna
come with me dude
rude rude rude rude can I help you guys
that was great
oh yeah we are like we had a mouse fun
dude ah kill burn see you later dude
you're killing I've been doing this so
what's up Jason how are you I'm really
good I'm oh this gets better every time
you look awesome
this is the greatest thing I've ever
seen in my life I know it's an audio
pocket Jory looks like I'm Waldo a 1930s
guy at the beach by the way that's how
they used to swim like I don't know in
pigs yeah the shower curtain wrapped
around your voice oh that's great are
you mixing are you mixing threads that
the Bible says you shouldn't right now
well look at this jacket he's mixing
men's clothes and women's clothes a show
on the back it's bedazzled oh it looks
like the inside of Elton John's [ __ ]
yeah that is what I imagine the inside
of Elton John's [ __ ] looking like
it's bad it's bad it's real bad what do
you think about Gruden right now where's
my dog right behind me okay good guys
got a pocket full of chipmunks but he
can't find his [ __ ] dog right now get
off of me listen dude I'm okay with it
you're okay with oh and three I'm not
okay but it's just like you know dude it
is what it is man what do you want me to
do flip out yeah dude we've won every
game we've been leading all three
quarters the first three quarters every
game sorry
not your fault here it's a rookie
quarterback no it's a first-time NFL
coach I love this is your headshot right
here dude this is your headshot you've
never looked so good
you know what makes it really good is
the fur on the shoulder it makes it even
better like when you add the fur on the
shoulder look at the fur on the shoulder
I love those bird nests I can't believe
your girlfriend thinks I hope he gets on
top of me and just pounds all right
before you come could you rip that gum
off your shoulder what it is man I'm not
talking [ __ ] I'm just saying if I was a
Raiders fan and a lot of my friends are
you Jay Rogers a lot of my good friends
are diehard Raiders fans everybody was
so excited Gruden's coming to town and
and he's done anything but purdue's I
get it he said the dumbest thing the
other day when they go what's your
problem he goes my our problem is we
don't have any good pass rushers and
pass rushers are so rare in the NFL and
so hard to get you just let the best one
go for him to say that it's ridiculous
to me cops are here for him to say that
it's ridiculous going re yep
bears are in first place what is this
this is okay so here you go zero wins
three sacks one forced fumble one
interception
that's the Raiders Khalil Mak alone four
sacks
three forced fumbles one fumble recovery
one interception one touchdown that's
just him alone that's the guy they let
go yeah he has more touchdowns he has
the same amount of touchdowns that the
Raiders have turnovers is that right
a forced fumble doesn't mean from a
recovery zero fumble recoveries they
only have one turnover he has more
attacks than their entire team
here's more I mean I don't know again
I've always been I never ever understood
Raiders letting their best player go and
they you know but they literally are
committed to the future don't like we
don't want to win today but yeah we're
not trying to win now we're gonna build
something in Vegas in a few years so I
guess that's what it is all right you're
gonna be missed Thursday we're all going
to with Sam's going to watch girls punch
each other in the tits but all of us are
going me Ren is easy Danis Antonio Court
Benjy everybody's going to tailgate at
the Rams Vikings Thursday night game do
you know that they used to throw a squid
on the ice yeah well you guys can go the
wrestling thing with the girls and throw
day cats in the ring or clams okay sorry
about that our he's being rude again
he's drunk it works out for Cleo in
Chicago it clearly is they're in first
place and look at the damage this guy
has done in the NFL yep but it really is
one of those things where we were saying
when you were outside I feel like the
Raiders are going you know what [ __ ] our
last two years in Oakland we're gonna
build something in Vegas in a couple
years and they're just not gonna try to
win not nothing I mean I don't want to
lose I just feel that I mean I get it
dude I have no idea what the Steelers
are doing the same thing with Le'Veon
Bell I have no idea where he's gonna
play but I don't think it's gonna be in
Pittsburgh if you are Cleveland when you
go after that guy I mean you got
probably about three seasons before you
have to pay that defensive lineman and
three seasons before you have to pay
quarterback the quarterback that guy's a
great running back why not go after him
yeah our Tampa to Tampa is another team
that I could see him playing for
yeah but you're I mean what what do you
think see what's-his-face the
quarterback for our Tampa Bay right now
what's his name Fitzgerald Fitzpatrick
Fitzpatrick this is every time Fitz
Patrick starts he always starts on fire
and lights it up and everyone's like hey
dude he's found it he playing Danny [ __ ]
last night yeah and then he teeters off
every time every time you look at it
when he was with the Jets what was the
other teams at he's with where he just
lit it up and then he went to [ __ ] Ari
are you worried about your team yeah
they play good the other night that is
not the guy they thought he was he was a
one-year quarterback oh he is definitely
not the guy you thought he was
I did
I agree I agree but but Zeke is great
and then they lost their two top
receiving targets well that's the
problem
real Hillary when you include Witten if
I'm a defensive coordinator and I owe me
got Dallas next week all I do is go stop
Zeke beat Dallas you go [ __ ] still you
go single coverage on everybody and you
try to stop Zeke you don't worry about
the receiving corps you don't worry
about their tight end you don't worry
about their number two receiver you
don't worry about [ __ ] here's what's
interesting all of our locks of the week
let's look at this week's schedule and
let's try to get our bet DSi lock of the
week by the way my lock was I took
Oakland ah first first half lock of the
week and a one that wasn't your pick
yeah was I mean that's your pick every
week but you've said somebody else I
want Oakland first half lock of the week
i-i-i-i Rams
I like do dinos could be in trouble huh
Vikings are
exactly here's an interesting stat
exactly 500 on week three very rare
there one one and one so are the Browns
yep crazy yeah it was grinding day one
they act like they won the Super Bowl I
love it who Jason rouse he was just
[ __ ] his fist over there in the
corner I are you interested it's not I I
rather be in the sport you'd rather be
in it like you'd rather be playing like
corner backers yeah I dig that I dig
that you don't even like hockey right
it's not a question I like all
competitive elements to lie anomie yeah
so anything like gangbangs can this
cheek take out all these guys I've seen
that live live Congrats thank you but
I'm just curious somewhere how you
invest because it seems like that
there's a I don't know there's no
loyalty
you could beYOU you guys are not loyal
to your team's like long terms what are
you talking I disagree that it's a good
observation photo and that's an older
guy taking a [ __ ] right now man you're
taking a long [ __ ] too dude maybe long
long well you should bend your knees it
will come out easier you don't have to
stand and over a bucket
oh I gotta live my whole life and not
heard that me and just buns ari Ari you
got buns or bread or hamburger buns can
I thank you please do you have bread of
or preferably a hot dog bun in a dish
glove or a hamburger bun and we can have
like a sloppy joe kind of vibe do you
have a hot dog yeah when you get back
from Austin do you have to go take a
[ __ ]
no I already grabbed a fistful of [ __ ]
beat off a little bit in it then put
your dick in a hot dog bun and take a
picture I got Christmas cards to send
this years they've seen mine
I wonder shows by the way what put me
off of your Christmas list
you're my MailChimp okay what yes um it
was a concert assault on your your
dignity and your I don't know why why
cuz you guys would freak out so to kind
of distract you from the least important
freak out [ __ ] yeah I had to throw a
couple logs on the fire literally so you
have to go really mindless primal when
people are in a state of crazy maniac I
reserved a bunch of hamsters in the cage
not used to being another backyard so I
poop yeah I don't my own [ __ ] I go full
chimpanzee and start throwing mud darts
around and it was you who would you it
was you and Nath in one hotel room yeah
you would already ten do I think you
guys knew each other better
yeah I was kind of you know I was really
yeah that kind of happened didn't it I
don't understand why you would I like
Center me out like that and shame
because you were the one that was
[ __ ] in hotel room hey why don't you
read your own declaration or
independence with the log father liveth
chapters 307 father no that was uh that
was a very it was Lord of the Flies in a
van no dude when what's the fat guy's
name again we'll see yeah he shot his
wife and with the jail a week after we
got the hilarious thing is that you guys
hired him to be your driver and then
found out he's legally blind and can't
drive yeah it usually irritated to and
very sensitive to his childhood did he
cry yeah he cried three times we laughed
at him and
we videotape why was he crying you were
fat remember that I used to be a fat kid
in everyone somber and I go you were
baking I love how you guys like help me
from bastardizing the story but you guys
are on going to the border and you had
like drugs and booze in it and you hid
it in like a ditch border and it came
back for it later
yeah we hid a gun you remember we in a
god Ari had pinned it behind the Denny's
like a ball of job Jager and some
marijuana
and then use on the way back you picked
it up it was still there so [ __ ]
funny hider yeah yeah you just pinned
the exact location behind some
industrial area or something like that
you know why did you have a guy I don't
I don't think anybody's done anything to
that level with zero help that we had
right yeah yeah I gotta be honest with
you the funniest I've led my life and
I'm not lying when I say the funniest I
laugh in my life was what we had we'll
see driving so I'm cranking up opera
yeah awkward orange we were just what
does that mean I broke them with a
little Clockwork Orange I mozart like
full blast and then once the the locusts
descend call them re Sam myself and
Chris and he's already in a state of
panic you know when it's like a shark
attack feeding frenzy so we're just
pulling off ears and noses yeah and he's
in charge of our lives he's driving
there's nothing stopping him from
[ __ ] fluoride off a bridge and taking
it so he jumped out at the stoplight and
Ted he had a pencil in his ass that
again again that's what I mean where
I followed you all the way on the puzzle
it's that that that you you that
somebody snaps and then all these things
that they've been holding back from
their childhood think about will see is
that like every day you meet him he has
a new special disease or something so
it's like it's called excuse yeah well
you know I like to like five years ago
he got this like fatal back disease they
says he had a fat ass that you know so
back then was that he had been somebody
shove the pencil up his [ __ ] that
sounds fun he was working at Staples as
a sharpener costume didn't fit right
uh-huh
it's a pencil actually I've had a pencil
in my ass but it was uh I used to do
push-ups naked or her in the when I was
in college president yeah and when I do
them day people in there the class guy
because I pull my pants down to my knees
and just start doing push-ups and the
course you did one of the students
overhand stabbed me with a pen in the
[ __ ] yeah like he viewed those look
that's called a hammer by the way you
could never run for Canadian Supreme
Court after that story I've never voted
I don't even own a flag flag are he's
wearing one right now re are you still
[ __ ] yes I'm disappointed that it's
you over pickles it smells so bad in
there the air freshener on the wall
behind you just puked its melting okay
wow wow look a whole lifetime without
seeing that yep and again not looking
just gonna look at this hat right here
Alliant boy you've got uni riced irony
have you ever gone for a colonic
re hey have you gone for a colonic dude
the guy needs medical somebody oh no
grab a piece please I want to see the
end with the black head up guys please
go to our rate react the black strippers
guys please go to our patriotism
no matter what laughing he needs it's
weird
I didn't all of our patreon money will
now be going to get re help have you
read a colonic re how did that feel the
one where the guy spits in your [ __ ]
and then puts his dick in that's called
the mud hammer ya know but you didn't
feel better after that yeah they know
err no they're supposed to put salt
water Wow
yeah did you get shot not even good luck
is he alright
he's not alright oh my god yeah those
are Paulo bleeding so much I didn't I'm
not looking I don't know what's wrong
with these guys but I'm horny can see
these guys are all blah blah blah I'm
not looking
oh do me a favor re wipe the blood blood
whole but put a hole in the toilet paper
so it looks like your fingers cut off
and it's sitting on a napkin
that's cool push magic here put your
fingers through the toilet the blood
hole in the middle and hey [ __ ] knuckle
of the band yeah I'm not looking run
into Denny's and go there's been a
horrible accident
I got [ __ ] knuckle blood darts all right
what is your girlfriend think of this
you still got girlfriend that is an exit
wound dude you have an exit wound for an
[ __ ] dude these guys you need a
tourniquet on your [ __ ] right now you
need a tourniquet on your [ __ ] it
looks like someone backed over a kid
with a garden weasel yeah what are those
things where they just show you blocks
and different things you guys look let's
say yeah is there meat in that hello
guys there's a good chance our he's
gonna die and you can make a bet on
over and under and our friends but DSi
bet DSi for all your Betty needs go to
bet D si.com or Dottie you use the promo
code punch 25 get $25 back and cast you
can bet it on everything in anything
dude you can bet it on UFC Caliente
Cagefighting Ari's bloody [ __ ] you
name it you can bet it bat deep esse
what you bet on football this Thursday
go punch room guys yeah you can
you can't that in that you totally go to
bet decide I'm gonna go lock of the week
Rams over Vikings lock of the week
that's my lock of the week now I'm 1 for
2 so bet DSi must be loving when Johnny
comes back from jerking off to Ari's
bloody [ __ ] oh we should that was
from his ass yeah that's cool or you
didn't tell me you could do that yeah
it's really neat isn't it what is that
it's like a weird kaleidoscope of rouges
and reds yeah it's like a it's like the
unwanted rows that's what your [ __ ]
is yeah are it's the unwanted rows are
always red always ready okay it looked
like you're away pan 1/2 of a
pomegranate or something like that yeah
but that's clearly you've got some heavy
parasites something bad is happening
deep inside of his body maybe I'm not
afraid to say that arty might not be
with us much longer
but that's a thing his immune system is
probably boosted cuz he's gonna slow
bleed
well he's Jewish and they have shitty
immune systems anyways because they
don't get along with anybody so they
just had to [ __ ] each other and now they
got like some weird kind of [ __ ]
blood disorder yeah yeah for sure yeah
that's like carrier and then your wife
is a carrier then there's a one in four
chance that your child dies a horribly
painful death by the age of about six
that's what God does to people would you
incest yeah yeah two of my brothers died
from the gang rape oh really
yeah I I would say I'm sorry to hear
that survival a bit shocked the cop shot
him
oh if you were to call my dick a cop
sure shot him three times then behind
the ear over the top of the head Johnny
pull up this week's schedule we can get
to our bet DSi locked wait you pull up
the schedule please - honey Johnny oh I
wouldn't touch Bengals Falcon honey why
don't sleep Johnny's doesn't look happy
maybe he has a blown-out [ __ ] Lions
Cowboys that's garbage
Cowboys getting Cowboys are getting
three and a half points Cowboys are
getting it good I wouldn't touch that
what else
keep going Johnny bucks bears uh yeah I
wouldn't touch it
this is uh because now they're two men
one that both those teams are two and
one Eagles Titans I don't like Packers
bills San Francisco is garbage and they
were garbage with Garoppolo and now he's
done for the year six minus five on the
road at Denver Kansas City - five I like
that too Kansas City is [ __ ] for real
if you like it so much why don't you
marry it I didn't say that
Kansas City's real dude
can't do it I'm calling the finals as
this finals the Superbowl right now
Raiders first half
Raiders first no it's going to be IDs
he'll be Kansas versus Kansas isn't a
team Kansas City Kansas City Rams Rams
yep I'm gonna call it right now right
now
I mean everybody's an injury away from
something that but dolphins Patriots I
don't I think the Patriots might be in
trouble yeah I think so yeah I think
that they hate each other they're one
and two Tom Brady had like a hundred
years now I tell you what they get a
Edelman back and then they get Josh Josh
Gordon to him and they get all it I wish
I could get out of this anyway no I'm
saying I don't like that game at all I
would take the Dolphins and ten points
basically it's nine and a half what
we're looking at here how many people
can this is the line from the early line
from to Dayton yeah yesterday afternoon
Browns Raiders
I think the Browns might get their
second win there it's a traders but man
Oakland just doesn't how many people can
run in this room what do you mean like
run around on it these two can I can't
why is that none of us can none of us
can
oh oh oh some more stuff to talk about
Oh real quick have what you have you
made your pick you know okay have you
been listening to the podcast stuff I
want to talk I'm super excited yeah I'm
gonna take Raiders off first half that's
my cold hard Lock Jets Jags mm9 has so
many points though Cardinals Seattle
that's a garbage game right there oh I'm
gonna hate watching that Saints Giants
I'll do I like the Saints in that eye
lines only three yeah time for yeah
49ers are [ __ ]
yeah makes you get Kaepernick now I know
there's no way that will happen on dude
look at this next line there's no way
that's real Ravens Steelers Steelers are
long lines you guys are reading the
wrong lines go to our good friends at
bet TSI hey guys Alliance just so you
know so it's not the same as it was a
few years ago when they played let me
just say this to you guys
this week is a very exciting week for
all things comedy while we look this up
I want to congratulate all things comedy
um I'm gonna die me get re steak on this
all things okay we're doing it speaking
of naked push-ups and there it is okay
why is your three balls a dude it's one
big nut followed by one with a pen in
your ass so it's not gross okay just
that not the tip and like the cap end
but the other end you lose it so here's
the thing right all all things comedy
has now teamed up with Comedy Central
and they're going to be doing projects
together
so congratulations al magical bill burr
and everybody in Burbank who works
really hard on that punch-drunk has been
ride-or-die since day one so we're proud
to talk about that mostly died mostly
died but we have rode we have rode now
this is a big week also for our good
friend bill burr who was on our 300th he
is playing the forums with Joe bartnik
and Dean Delray so I have my tickets
guess where I bought my tickets on Sikhi
that's right see geek for all your
ticketing needs dude these guys want got
their tickets for the Rams game you
probably that's crazy I wanted to
support I wanted to support we got 10
tickets you got tickets to to Rams game
on seeking real and literally found them
cheapest ones we're like what are the
cheapest seats it's so easy to do did it
right on the app and a good friend Steve
Rannazzisi also in all things company
bought the tickets I go hey don't forget
to use the code punch-drunk Wow
and guess what happened we got $20 off
of that 20 bucks
thank you see geek man I've gone seen
Allison chains I've gotten seen out
every since they started working on us
Allison chains I once saw K rocks almost
acoustic Christmas on mushrooms you name
it
and I will be going to the forum to
watch two of my favorite comics work it
out BAM support the team seeking for all
your ticketing needs dude and guess what
it's almost playoff time so guess what
boom gonna be buying some playoff
tickets yes I'll probably be taking on
Johnny's team and we will run a train on
those guys
thanks to seeking I'll be bringing
Johnny with me Johnny will be paying for
the tickets but he'll be coming with me
go to seeking for all your ticketing
needs we love seeking we appreciate all
the things it is the promo code is
punch-drunk grab those tickets now
you're talking bucks off don't be a
dummy all you got to do is get the app
have the app in your phone no matter
where you are in the country no matter
where you are in the world
just look up it finds where you are and
it tells you what's cool what cool
events are right next to you so get the
app use the code punch-drunk and that
get you 20 bucks off whatever ticket you
buy suck it
okay alright
c7 I think Dober I think the rams are
going to run through Minnesota that
might be my lock is Rams over Minnesota
Sam's is not going to change
it's going to be Raiders in the first
half Raiders first half get is for
Raiders first half and my lock isn't
Raiders lose second half that will be
our lock of the week every week you want
to win money put $50,000 on Raiders
first half and then put another $50,000
on them [ __ ] it up that's just rude I
think Cincinnati will probably beat
Atlanta Atlanta is in deep [ __ ] Atlanta
is in deep [ __ ] yeah what do you into
your offensive coordinators how are you
saying no we five defensive starters
done for the year
o-5 both savory year both safeties done
for the year we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to get a safety we're gonna
have to go get us so you know who's
available I'm here to get me I would
like him I would love him you guys are
dealing with in the middle of football
season
yeah is this in the middle of the other
games in we still out it's early yeah
and you guys put a lot of attention at
the earliest
ages of it well yeah we were just
excited that it's back yeah you know but
is so that all three of our teams are
just probably garbage is Sunday's still
a football day in America yeah it is the
football the football day not all
football the football day see I hate the
fact that they just automatically are
not interested in signing Eric Reid bass
clearly need a safety we need to not
interested well I just said that they
were not interested how many of you
football players you think did still do
dogfighting well good question
that's a great quote maybe seventy that
all that [ __ ] aggression and [ __ ]
like that you can only beat your wife
for how long how many days is that
probably three hours a day and then it
starts to get a little child yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like I gotta catch balls
with these hands you [ __ ] punch
yourself who gets married to a
professional athlete chicks and makes
straight cash homie yeah no professional
shoppers liars [ __ ] good kind are you
say disagreeing we had a couple of hot
chicks hey hey hey whoo man Aaron how
many football players high school
sweethearts James still married to
highschool squeal she knows he bangs
everything he moves but these are
football Ron James of football Bron Bron
James LeBron James yeah yeah he [ __ ]
Apple everything everything dude is that
the guy who smoked crack at the
whorehouse no that is Lamar Odom a he to
[ __ ] everything as well does he go back
playing sports after smoking crack and
banging hookers he's now supposedly
going to play in China or somewhere like
that and then here's the funny married
still no dirty split she she she canned
him yeah and now he's D he's been
degraded to another league or downgraded
yes yeah we can't even a spot in the big
three he can't dude how crazy this you
hear the WNBA players are complaining
about getting money and then
the third professional basketball league
after the big three the big three does
way bigger numbers the big Slayer
Metallica and Megadeth yeah after that
it's ice cube ice cubes summer
basketball league where he gets all the
older players who still think they can
play they play like blue half-court
there's a four point shot it's great on
I enjoy watching it it's been fun I
enjoyed it especially when there's it
there's smart marketing wise because
it's when there's nothing else but
baseball on so it kind of gives you
another alternate everybody know Mobley
is like super grain wanting to fight
every but Johnny LeBron in it this
season
I mean Kobe yeah he won't do it dude he
said he's interested in doing it really
yeah and what just playing in the big
three in the summer oh the big three
yeah I mean it would definitely get a
viewership for sure sure
and then duty Scott looking like holy
[ __ ] they're selling out arenas dude
yeah they're getting pretty packed
because it's like oh the whole league
will play in one day so if you get
tickets let's say they're at Staples
Center you watch all four games of all
four teams play so it's not just like
they travel like a concert like they go
on tours the whole season is them going
on tour so they go to all the arenas and
play their whole season so when you go
you get to watch essentially every game
that week there's only like four or
eight teams or some [ __ ] right there the
cover band of athletes ya know the super
group of athletes yeah yeah but you're
old it's like it's like you know like a
senior league yeah but it's like think
of a band that's like couldn't sell out
like if you like a like one of us into
United States millions of peaches no no
like like a you know you get all those
tours where it's like there's seven
bands that you're like oh you know yeah
this it's a nostalgic way off it's like
that yeah that's what the big three
seems like to me are you like oh I went
and saw [ __ ] and it's a comic-con with
action yeah uh-huh
cuz that comic-con for basketball you're
like oh I remember this guy hey we got a
call should we take it it's a car show
let's take this call and see what we're
dealing with here
I hope it's re-stick on the other end of
that call it probably will be
did you hello you are on the air with
punch-drunk who are you and what the
[ __ ] do you want out of jail we thought
you were dead yeah dude your [ __ ] is
great man you know yeah I mean you know
yeah wait what tell me I've been
thinking about it we got this new
gymnast [ __ ] it worse you know she done
took gymnastics off their childhood and
actually popped her a little [ __ ] thing
that hymen hey check your so they didn't
name me like a chef de Partie or
something up here now
I don't know where to start guess where
my fingers are
all right so let's start with this new
gymnast at work and who popped her [ __ ]
out comes in Raiford University
sounds like he's falling downstairs and
talking and that's always the case so
you and your mother we're having dinner
you and your mother are having dinner at
Fuddruckers and the women's volleyball
team walks in to your luck yeah average
for Ash is like goddamn Clydesdale you
know we haven't needs a question we
haven't needs equestrian games down here
but who gets to folks about that [ __ ]
you know not me great question that's a
great what about that where's your
mother
did your mother notice that you were you
know obviously very stoked about these
women walking in 15 times I mean when I
stated legit thoroughbreds boys I mean
I've never seen the accumulation they
many tall [ __ ] I mean it makes me
want to go to race for I respect that I
respect that maybe it's not
yeah but they say me I wanted you to get
me in with one of these on porn source
we got the end of goddamn streaker man
this is a little get 10 plus years now
10 plus years since we rape somebody
since you've been like yeah for sure for
sure I respect it [ __ ] out of that dude
I respect I mean I would read the hell
I'd have to do some shady [ __ ] to get it
but it was Riley right now riley reid is
the one that was on the naughty show and
she showed Duncan Trussell her [ __ ]
oh that's gross yeah gross it's totally
rouse oh yeah I do she's a pretty hot
one she's hot and super filthy Abbyson
[ __ ] boy I mean on Instagram I just got
overwhelmed on there hey I had to pull
out a couple sometimes you know I'm not
really into the high def porn but if
they're super hot it's all good though
what about the NFL though I could not
love you more
uh yeah they've been now who's your team
again well you know I'm from Carolina so
naturally I'm a panther stand by a lot
of the Cowboys won't really tell many
people I wouldn't either I would know
well you know I support I support DAC or
whatever but hey I don't know if he's a
long term hey my question is what do you
think about up the upcoming basketball
season I can't wait to see LeBron and
that yellow purple ball yeah you think
he's gonna do well oh they gonna shoot
some bad this year
you think so it's too late God
we're lucky girl what's that what's that
yeah yeah seems tweeting the whole times
hundreds of times bro
I respect the [ __ ] out of that I respect
the [ __ ] out of that tweeting Skyler
Stone Oh real quick real quick okay I'll
tell I'm gonna take my I'm gonna take my
medicine give it to me give it to me
I can't oh thank you buddy
Skyler Sam's a good guy he's not so
wrong a lot low no but I'm sure you took
it the wrong way he's not a bad guy at
all hahaha thank you buddy
all right I take it I take it I own it
wait Johnny you snitchin [ __ ] okay okay
so I wanna get into a couple things ah
Ari
yeah what day we're doing hot dog what
day are we doing ha ha tweet Adam tweet
tweet are your question okay I did you
uh did anybody watch Tiger Tigers win
this weekend yes dude I love it
HGH and [ __ ] Waffle House [ __ ] we'll
get you back odd the big board that's
praise good golf what he's been playing
good golfer to last year I mean a lot of
a lot of top-five finishes he's juicing
dude is he by that's my opinion
I don't know I I believe so you don't
[ __ ] crash and burn and then
magically at 42 get your game back and
start competing with these twenty year
olds well he changed his game after back
surgery he changed his swing he changed
everything
what yeah yeah he'll dominate the
seniors to her yeah they'll dominate the
seniors to her it is my belief that he's
allegedly AC agent and bacon waffles
[ __ ]
but you're that's just you're just
wildly thinking that you don't have like
sources that are like well I believe
that yeah I haven't heard him being
accused of that oh he has in the past
well yeah in the past been linked to
guys who have been who have been what
I'm saying in the last four years
lessons let's come back let's look at
this dude you're the LPG veil you're the
PGA right you're not getting any ratings
the only time you get ratings is one
Tiger place is anyone gonna drug test
the sky and then if he fails tells him
he failed it who does that help
nobody even the guys on the tour need
him to be good so that they but I mean
you can make the same argument for the
UFC I mean they do way better when Brock
Lesnar's not test apologized I'm gonna
start looking the other way what's this
what rouses uh authority you know I
think it was just about the Fox family
yes yeah I'll be rude Ari
you are right take them I deliver the
PGA world is way better with Tiger yeah
so he see the drug test they would never
tell you like I'm convinced I am
convinced LeBron James is juicing I'm
convinced Vanessa Serena Williams is
juicing they get you mungus numbers that
other people don't necessarily get you
think everybody that is good no I don't
say that at all at all
you just name the best player in
everything Warriors I said to players uh
Tiger yep LeBron yeah Serena
three those are the three different
sports these are the top three player
all three of those have in common they
win they all have the best things to sow
their black admit they're black they're
they're black their bodies are like
insanely with the their bodies are built
like no one else in their group nobody
else is built like that at that level
everybody that was drafted with LeBron
James has their game has fallen off out
of the league they're always hurt now
LeBron is built every he's a Brett Favre
you could say brett farr nolan ryan are
the other ones who played super long for
a very long time but none of them were
shredded like these guys are you
look at Serena Williams compared to her
own sister it's they don't even look
like they're related I have a question
give her Ben Johnson yeah do you see the
year before and then the year yeah I
mean look at these people they are built
like brick [ __ ] yeah well they have
there's a lot of money at stake they
have access to the best science and
technology available do I can keep that
money train go dude female tennis
players their game the bottom drops out
of 30 she is winning at 38 when her
sister isn't even doing that well her
own sister the same genetic pool do you
see how she destroyed her sister like it
wasn't even close though she played her
sister oh yeah I like and recently just
beat her she annihilate her and
humiliated her you know you're wiser the
older well that's like Eli Manning not
being as good as Peyton Manning it must
be drugs or Cooper Manning Cooper
Manning is also the same genetics or the
janitor at my high school mr. Manning
who's always had other kids toenails
everybody at LeBron James's draft class
he's either I the league always hurt or
you know nobody's built like him he's
built like a brick [ __ ] at that age
have your best statistical year almost
at what 34 Roger Clemens did it he was
clean good point Ari good point Barry
Bonds was good right through these other
guys that played at such a high level at
a very late age none of them were built
like the way these players are built and
look and and you go back to old Tiger
Woods pictures that guy was built like a
he's pretty [ __ ] shredded for a
golfer I mean like Big Shoulders he has
that weird like [ __ ] cro-magnon
[ __ ] eyebrow area skull you know just
like all that stuff he's built like you
know and I know LeBron James has always
had a big bill but dude I mean that's
him in high school
right and that's still not even close to
what he is now well of course not his
body wasn't even developed yet I'm
jacked
you guys can believe whatever you want
how about this dude you
are you here this about John Jones no
what good know that basically he
snitched on people to give a [ __ ] in
here that can you believe that
yes [ __ ] what [ __ ] [ __ ]
what'd he say John he [ __ ] he is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah he [ __ ] himself too he fought
he's always been a [ __ ] he ratted he's
a liar right again yep he's always a
little liar so even a snitch he's always
been a [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's why he's
gonna not be very welcomed when he comes
back I do he's gonna get booed a lot I
get that he is now the heel he is now
the heel he's gonna sleep in yeah all
the million dollars and [ __ ] rolling
around in it yep listen that's exactly
what he's become I'm not a fan of that
what do you think he'd say about your
career
Bob my career yeah it's just gonna carve
so hard I mean he would beat the living
[ __ ] out of the odd of all I would just
shell 607 teeth leave me alone what
would be your defense against this
beating to cry cry I faked my own death
punch myself in the face
ya know you doing it wrong kid whack
yeah and then I'd act like I died and
then he'd run off cuz he's like [ __ ] I
can't beat this rap - he does something
very young confession to me and then I
would show up of my own at the trial and
testify how he killed me if you wanna
wait two weeks away from the UFC yeah is
that right yeah two weeks um Saturday
yep or one week ah it's not this
Saturday it's following Saturday notes
yeah we are dates following yeah oh yeah
yeah like what what 10 days 12 days
whatever I'm excited for that one
yeah me too dude that's gonna be good
it's a good fight I think I'm sorry now
the thing that calm that's gonna lose
hey I'm starting to think the opposite
of that really yeah I'm starting to
think Connors gonna win I don't really
know why egusi fighting this guy could
never get off who's tough undefeated
undefeated Russian yeah brush fat ass
there's is he is he
what's the body type in comparison you
see more of a taller aging no but I mean
like do you guys do you ever take
steroids no I wish I could have wise
okay yeah you still can now I took him
for like two seconds when I was on that
[ __ ] plane me know when I was on the
[ __ ] wild world of spike
they gave I found some guy who have I'm
like I'll try them and then I'm like I
wanna [ __ ] shoot myself yeah shoot
needles I hate that [ __ ] but there's
like oral why would take rather than
carry the sourdough around shoot the
needle I don't want you me so like
needles shoot I hate I pass out when I
draw blood he really from Ahri's rectum
and we're back
who wouldn't so re what is going on with
this bag of bats what are we doing this
I think we're doing it October 23rd
October 23rd we're shoving hot dogs in
our butts can I go to frozen or unfrozen
whoo oh yeah I remember from from skank
fest okay all right we're gonna talk to
him well question guys can I can I can I
go or Sam I lost this bet to you can I
go into the subway and say excuse me
ladies and gentlemen I'm sorry if I can
have a moment of your time
I'm down on my luck right now I've lost
the bet to my friends and I have to beg
for $1 please did it help me no you
can't say anything
so all so I thought you're gonna say
that about the USA chant yeah you you
can't say please give me my you got be
like
you gotta be like I'm down please money
you can't say I lost I lost it yeah you
can't say that but I'm fine do it just
get the money you're still doing the hot
dog yes are now Johnny is has there been
some belief that maybe there's a bag of
bet another bag of bats hasn't been paid
it was a mistake
okay so what is the score right now bag
of bets oh okay I'm getting maybe he has
to beat off too right
I'm hot dog like he owes three he owes
three I owe one goes to inclusion yeah
and and raise I am raised money
what's the buy dogs have to jerk off and
come during the show under the table
you know live on skype yeah and I can't
no assistance no assistance no anything
I have to be staring at them I can but I
have to be staring at them and it's not
paid off until I actually come live on
the show which is gonna be I'm I will
not be able to I mean I'll do it but I
won't close my zero way I can come this
time remember to turn on the video so
you don't have to do it again yes you
but I mean that's gonna be a lot of
trouble for the network know what the
thing but I'll do it but I won't be able
to come I literally will not be able to
come none has not paid off till I come
then I just am never on the show again
yeah
I just never be on the show again put a
deposit right I'll be on skype every
week until I come
yeah and I'll never be on the show and
our show will get clearly canceled if
you can't come I've canceled you know I
mean it's like hey watch Tebow come try
to come every single week on all things
comedy like brought to you by Comedy
Central I love it I mean
I'm cool with it if you guys want the
demise of this show for this one stupid
[ __ ] bet just go into it and [ __ ]
open it up and read everything at once
that were willing to do this or not
oh you saying did that on a patreon
episode can you up it for like to get
more onus points is like if you beat off
in the one-up Ari's I will literally
starting next week next week I pay the
jerk-off one and then every week after
that every week after that until I can
actually come okay I will no longer be
in studio until I come all right because
that wasn't a bet I have to be on skype
skyping in and you guys would watch me
jerk off for two hours I have the
solution
yeah Jason Tebow jerks off during the
patreon what is that what does that mean
that way he can stay I go in an omni
store basement and beat off into the
Harmony store he gets it so we got the
Skype going down into the basement and
we do show why you jerk off at home
Johnny nobody does especially all things
comedy it's the so what do we do here
Jason I think I just told you I will not
be on this show until I actually come
and this show will be me jerking off for
two straight hours I like that that is a
good [ __ ] view that's a weird-looking
garbage fire yeah why don't you try and
draw another one then and just do
whatever comes out why don't I put a hot
dog in my ass okay I agree three of us
are doing a hot dog in the ass that's
the deal you don't did your call at all
at all things comedy fast alright no
like live no we're doing here Brad worst
brat worst Jason Jason is gonna show I'm
jerking off he's gonna throw i'm sure
hot dog in his house
I'm tricking on oh I have a quill be
jerking off on this show for two
straight hours for the rest of eternity
okay that's what our show will be
Jason Ralph ones if you jerk-off with a
hot on the hot dog and then put it in
someone's ass your chance to get like a
free t-shirt or it's just a bet let's go
there we go a little Irish you for your
love letter
the Crimson poem the good news is I get
to sleep in now on Tuesdays so type in a
B topper to know there's a lot of joke
ones in there that we put in as a goof
and then when they get drawn out okay so
Johnny pull them out yeah what smoking
yeah what I was just gonna do that
magical is real cool about it yeah this
microphone smells like it smells like
cotton candy I love it eat a hot eat a
hot Carolina Reaper that's we're done it
during the show I'm cool bad okay that
is brutal I eat the whole thing I don't
even know if any of us could do a
one-week ad for sex in backpage.com
that's yeah really did that yeah you
want it out yeah because you can't
really do that back page anymore well
that's what we did with uh we did the
gay website yeah loser has to take take
the SAT and post the real results we did
that already been done one of us know
yeah when you were gone those guys from
it dirty sports did it okay
shock your balls or neck because you're
gonna be I don't want anybody go I would
never have done that so let's pay
attention all right shock balls or neck
if you're a man you do balls oh but it's
your image your neck oh it shoes dozen
or no if you're man you do balls read it
right that arrow is on this pot mani she
doesn't do bag of bass yes
did that mean if you're a man about it
or if you're actual I assume if you're a
man about it know if you're a man you do
balls Oh mine shocked my goddamn balls
yes I think it means man but why would
it send balls so it's clear that
somebody added that at the bottom I
didn't I did I was doing it as a goof
and if that blows up in my face fine
tazer might not god I hate this show if
a woman chases her vagina with a liquid
it could be a problem so that's why
there's like hold if you're mixed though
take a shot of your own piss shot of
your own piss yeah teba yeah I don't
have to come in this room ever again
so this homeless guy until you have $40
re you can pull that one out because
it's already been done well it's gotta
notices do not repeat until October 24
2018 does that mean it's like so you
don't repeat it too soon it just says do
not repeat his handwriting is that I
don't know weren't either it's like
Sam's me now you out he wouldn't yeah we
he's doing it right now I don't know he
wasn't making worse all right
yeah but how's that gonna be worse it's
actually do you homeless for a year and
a half because it used to say 20 and
then we added 40 on there nobody's done
that cuz that's the one we thought you
did you had to do but it was actually
training the homeless begging thing
homeless baking what well the thing that
you have to do were you begged for 40
bucks
yeah what about it sorry someone came to
my door what if we're taking it out it's
in pop it's an impossible one okay just
so you guys know oh I know how hard that
is all the ones that have we are being
paid off our 48-hour Hitler stash five
tweets in public okay hold on hold on
that's something say add something to
that
okay after someone draws it yeah you
can't just do it right away because
there's no Hitler's - let's get this
down I say exactly
thirty days afterwards you go full
Hitler session no shaving for those 30
days and then you go Shi Hitler stash
that so you see enough for 30 days but
we all have full stashes I do right now
okay well then you're good then all
right okay but it's just gotta be it's
gotta be a full just major breakdown
it's gotta be a full word just put on me
you have to already didn't you already
do that one yes you did that right yes
did you tweet it yes people use it as
their avatar for their [ __ ] Twitter
accounts we could take that one out
Hitler's - Ari did what did that - take
it out No Ari's the one that did it I
did not as well oh you did how much - is
out there okay I did have a pubes - from
my bet with Coleman no remember you did
this oh you did oh you had all those
kids doing the sig Heil so everybody's
done that bed except for me and nany
okay now this one has an asterisk at the
top it says Sam must approve shave
swastika into head at least size of
small lighter must wear for three
straight days with no hat complete
within four months and this is one you
haven't voted on so you have to approve
it I don't even know what that means
that I think it you guys put this in
when he wasn't here yeah we put him when
he wasn't this we did Sam say yes or no
it's shaving a swastika in the head no
hat hey guys work out gasps go take what
oh this is fun
I mean yeah we we if it didn't we know
we know no no no where there's no way
you're gonna clip any other of us a
loophole the winner makes a three page
script gay porn this is that can paid
off serenity okay so here's the deal let
me tell you about that Rannazzisi wants
to do it wait wait don't put that away
you have that one I still have it you
read it out loud please
the winner makes a three page script gay
porn kissing a loud fondling chest but
is allowed with with boner pills it
seems like it says here with Molly and
boner pills that's that's that's a late
addition have to give me make doing
Molly optional I don't want to do Molly
I just want to make out what a sweet guy
are we filming that one or not yeah that
was our impression I was under that
umbrella she wants to do it as a live
thing at the off phase comedy fest well
October 20 I love that I love that idea
and show them we're gonna film it as
like a staged thing I have made a play
like I have proof of that
stage production yeah I'm like to kill a
mockingbird you have nothing to do with
that then you wait then you heard it
here first
hold on hold on 2018 all things comedy
festival will feature the gay porn
payoff from Steve Rannazzisi Thank You
Louie CK for making this happen
you have to tweet everything every time
you ejaculate for two weeks and say what
you ejaculated about I already had to do
that one every single time for two weeks
I liked it I did that well that's one of
the original ones I've lost you can keep
it in there okay but I've already I've
already lost that one a tweet I got a
lot of retweets for it Sam's looking
them up right now yeah hold on okay yeah
my ass I think we're gonna take this one
[ __ ] guy
a gay you have to jerk off the gay porn
and come live during the show the
jerk-off is in the bathroom and you have
to yell hard
it looks like that's ridiculous
no one will be able to do see those ones
you just aren't gonna be able to pull
off I'll do it I'll do it for fun just
anyway so you're just want me to give
that to you
we're all watching gay porn installs
next to each other but you got put money
on it but if you got put money on it
it's guy-on-guy porn yeah you're the
only one that'll be able to come from
yeah baby baby baby maybe probably a
hundred percent a hundred and ten he
already does that yeah you I do
so listen yeah and do put five hundred
bucks
things out of your comfort zone exactly
that's why it's out yeah we keep a hot
dog reverse kobayashi we can't do this
one again until 2020 but you must well
they're not gonna do it at all tornado
the thing we added though to make it
worse yeah we added but you must grill
it afterwards and eat it eat your own
dog and then Johnny subs it up your ass
while Aaron makes makes out with the
receiver that's that's good this is
something for everyone
that's gotta be my handwriting keep that
in I like the grilling and eating it and
who does Aaron make out with the winner
the guy who's getting the hot dog in the
ass haha that is something friend you're
not really a guy after you get a hot dog
yes you're a man you're a hot dog stand
this is this is the [ __ ] walk donut
time dressed like a [ __ ] on Santa
Monica it does say here terms to be
determined I don't know what that means
a condom or no condom how long does he
have to do it that's what the terms okay
well we until it comes right wait until
someone comes that's the kind of thing
we needed
figure out right now I said an hour hour
yeah I mean it's the training one is
walking around for an hour we gotta get
you dolled up though do we have to do we
want to have a time for that like time
it has to be at night make it five hours
make it five five hours on rollerblades
and a miniskirt and rollerblades with
two blown-out kneecaps that fire well
how have people keep shooting things at
me like all right like darts no no like
bullets Oh
loser gets hit by a car going must be
going over 75 miles an hour can you face
the car he's like testifying like buddy
doesn't want anyone to know his actual
[ __ ] identity I started [ __ ] kids
to the playground I would be so horrible
time that they would try and [ __ ] back
you gotta take a clear plastic bag Oh
suffocate yourself to death with a
plastic bag keep that one in clear
plastic bag to a sporting event and five
things go in chosen by the winner oh
that's a good score pians five that's a
good one that's one of my favorites what
was going to a [ __ ] football game you
got a dildo a handgun no dead rat your
mouth no phone baby head no no phone for
three days
Sam thinking about that right now one
day we made it worse three days no
nothing and now it's three should we
change that to make like make it five
iPad and all make it five days because
you know so you can still do texting on
your iPad like that yeah I know no
nothing no phone destroy your phone
you're not a lot of foam for a year no
phone for five days no internet for five
days no computer for five days no iPad
for five days no Internet connected
device you can watch TV it's like the
[Music]
three days with no phone everything's a
league
is legal no condom the other two guys
write an opening joke for the other dude
that's a good one
what would you do if you all whoever
loses the other to write their opening
joke and yet within a month you have to
do that joke is a paper have always
blood on it okay that's a good one must
take five photos with Ag a go-go dancer
at a gay bar
Sam show me phone no one did that I
listener did it it says oh let's take
five oh yeah that's right he did one
with Ag a go-go dancer at a gay bar
that's not that crazy that's easy that's
Johnny's Friday take take it out take it
out okay
that one's pretty easy I'll do these
ones then you guys don't want I'll take
them what do I win much all things
comedy sticker you got to wear a
mustache too pubes for one Episode pubes
of the other two guys where did that one
keep it in though yeah keep it in sure
wait pube mustache pew pew most has pew
beard during a show how about pube
eyebrows we're really all about this how
about this put my few eyebrows but they
go around to make a new hole a new
[ __ ] the unwanted wait wait Sam I got
one hold on let me get my cocoa but I
don't know they said look take a free
hat for a second Jason let me see
something
no no not you Jason the other chase Oh
Jason oh yeah your head is too full I
was gonna say me and Sam key you're in
are balled in you can what oh yeah do
you wanna get a horse tail what about
eyebrows and you have to eat all of the
pubes of everybody oh you're okay with
eyebrows are right all right I brought a
pubic swathe though well you're telling
a beard mustache an eyebrow
beard mustache
okay okay yeah 1/8 off and just change
it to eyebrows I'm like that's too easy
yeah you too for what wait wait wait we
put the eyebrows on for the whole show
yes yeah eyebrows mustache and beard
though guys the pube beard and mustache
it's so gross it's so horrible the smell
is it it is is it the hair around your
[ __ ] on your face this one Oh
yoga jumped ahead yoga on viagra at
least a one-hour class oh I'll come in
my throw one on the mat that's that's
easy
yeah you go out we should do it by Agra
and Jiu Jitsu Oh more it's more together
more loving do you want me to swap out
yoga for jiu-jitsu how about our just
arm wrestling with hard-ons that's
pretty tough if you're trying to tell
y'all just full-on gay [ __ ] and not even
for a bag of bats a guy's gotta take one
guy's dick in the bot is this about
sports or hot dogs of this yes most
sports of them all creatively [ __ ] bomb
yourself three times in 24 hours I had
to do that one I like let's up it to
more than that
what's a [ __ ] bomb you have to tweet how
much you love black dick or I like to
suck a nice big ass god no it says [ __ ]
mom yourself but does the other person
get to choose the [ __ ] mom or you just
have to do it yourself maybe that's how
you make it worse the other person gets
to pick what you write yeah that's good
yeah I'm fine with that I mean the
winner gets a text you three times like
right this right now Luis yeah and if
you're on stage as soon as you get off
yeah like you don't do right oh that's a
big I was in a movie I said you like a
cut-and-paste yeah you just have to copy
what I text you and just put it in your
tweet and tweet it yeah can I tell you
this is an addendum yes I only get 140
characters if I write it from my flip
phone so if you need me to send it to
the lady who sends like the tweets for
me it's gonna take a little bit longer
if it's worth if it's more than a
hundred and forty you're not worried
about any kind of meteor [ __ ] from that
what sending your dick to a lady who
gets off $20 too
tweet jerk-off - Magic Mike and finish
so this is just more that's another one
you would love to do right jerk-off the
magic might start a USA chant already
got that one oh yeah here's my plan you
guys Yankee playing game assuming we get
home filled on October 3rd as soon as
they do the flyover or the [ __ ]
national anthem boom that's wrong let's
strike so that's everything we probably
need more than that now send it yeah
feel free to send us that's what I'm
gonna strike wait turn okay and so
that's the guy the guy who said he would
shave a swastika in his head if Ryan
lost the fight he hasn't done it I sent
him a message on the Instagram account
that gave me they didn't reply well he's
no longer welcome to be a part of this
this tribe what can what can I do well I
just want to make sure we the other guy
has offered to do it the guy who won
he said I'll do it oh then let him do
and let that guy you know I don't know
what else I could do do you want me to
find that guy's address we go beat the
[ __ ] out of them yes
let's let's go watch that guy beat off I
just wanna notice one thing with this
show
kidnap him to make him jerk off a
gunpoint 350 year olds be da and wonder
why they had none of them only one of
them has a career and he's the only one
that's completely naked right now
you've been naked this whole show for
the beginning yeah a toe ring underwear
underwear and then I go oh and cliff
should we take this call yeah
take the call we did it guys let's see
we did it we could we should do next
episode all calls about about what an
old bag of second hour all bag of bets
hi you're on with Jason Tebow how are
you that looks okay I just bought my
take it's the festival in Phoenix so now
um I was wondering what day are you guys
doing a lot podcast
we don't know yet probably Friday either
Friday or Saturday it'll be Friday or
Saturday yeah well you dope cuz I I get
it on Friday come on listen we'll make
sure to wait for you and then you're
gonna be there Saturday as well yeah
I'll be there 400 oh yeah you won't miss
it then it won't be Thursday and it
won't be Sunday yes yes wait what'd you
say
walk so we might have just hung up on re
good there you are
oh she is good good there she is there
she is like a what day are we gonna do
the live pod the live pod got a ATC fest
it's one one day though it won't be
Saturday all day yes oh that's are all
Jason Ross's dates yeah so many dates so
many I love the venue names the abyss
you know hell's basement yeah the asylum
Hey look
Jerry's chuckle hut Jerry's chuckle hut
I love it yeah and Copenhagen actually
always performing there on December 4th
re are you gonna be there I'm December
14th
so I fly in on the second Slayers
playing on Copenhagen on December 2nd
you can pop that up yeah I don't know if
you're interested in Slayer and I know
I'm interested it's the last have you
ever seen Slayer I have once at Bonnaroo
they were great oh good because they're
retiring this year oh really
yeah sixties I'm glad that you took a
beat to acknowledge that what they're
doing is pretty epic no yeah and they
started off a lot of bands when they go
to festivals especially was not an
all-female like that like all metal and
that most of the crowd is not there for
them so they don't really know how to do
that for the first time in the year so
they do beg dumb jokes and [ __ ] just
layer no good to go I know which all for
this for you guys [ __ ] here we go
rocford Angel of Death yeah yeah it's uh
it's it's heart moving that's what we're
gonna be doing we're like I know I'm too
old for this but uh hey guys what's up
with this airplane food huh start
juggling who wants to watch me jerk off
yeah is that what happens when you get
into sports
hey challenge your heterosexuality yeah
dude you just get weird or you just end
up doing more drugs and going deeper
down into pornhub and actually no oh
here we go here we go open it up oh you
know who has a cigarette burned above
their [ __ ] unload that thing Ari
you're gonna need a [ __ ] something to
pull on a wine cork push it in but put a
hot cloth on it first and drain it oh
why don't you take a carrot peeler and
take that mole off the right wow he's so
naked yes he's got a flatter ass than I
do I don't even have an ass I just have
legs that go up to my back it's like a
fire hat with hair in it get a pair of
toenail clippers and Lance Sam's gonna
be writing a script right now what are
you doing
do you diary run out on our big event
coming out dear Oscar Mayer okay next
week can we can make it all call in bag
of bets episode you want to do a full
two hours on it how about the second
hour just keep calling no I mean in
between well like say some sports up but
everybody just call in
we'll take one bag of that suggestion
after another you and I are both on
skype next week
oh that's way better where are you I'm
gonna be jerking off oh okay all right
we're there again yeah you do what does
that even mean I'm just gonna jerk off
two hours on this show if I don't come
then I do it the following way yeah and
you just people go you gotta wear your
least favorite team jersey you never let
you do it ever
you just keep jerking and [ __ ] into
you look like beef jerky and so it's
going to be from now on
me jerking off for two hours for the
rest until you let me ask you something
would you suggest that we do - nothing's
nothing to suggest no like I mean you
gotta be having something and somehow
for you to pay this off that is that is
honors the spirit of the best so what
would you suggest I jerk off for two
hours okay
oh I'm not gonna eat my soup no more
jokes no my gags this is Tebow beats off
for the rest of time anybody against
that Tebow being off for the rest of
time it's gonna monitor his skills what
why don't you like it Johnny
he is great on the show I think he I
know Jason and I've such faith it's also
listen LeBron was great at Cleveland
he's gonna be even better on the Lakers
yeah that's right listen I believe in
Jason so much more than anybody else in
the world I believe Jason can be funny
and beat off at the same time how about
you just has to earnestly try for one
episode what he has to really try for
one episode if it doesn't happen but if
I don't come I'm fine with that job but
I believe in this guy I don't need I
know what will make me never come
whiskey
listening to you to [ __ ] Jack offs
heckle me the entire that's how about
this is he allowed to mute it and just
put the camera there and forget about
the camera and jerk no it's just going
to be my [ __ ] getting stroked on skype
to be fair the whitney marathon was
basically your [ __ ] a lot i think you're
great dude I was literally on I
literally Facebook live periscope
Oh periscope you have oh gods with
breast periscope I was on periscope for
18 straight hours
beaten no but I just kept getting my
dick out and smacking it on the phone
well that's why we like you so I was
like I don't think T paid that bad off
I'm like oh I really did yeah that was
that was probably the worst one you see
that
on my leg that swimmers come shot guys
that's been punch-drunk god I hope you
guys enjoyed watching Sam write a script
and tweet this entire episode yeah and
re being [ __ ] naked in an old man hat
and I will never be in the studio again
so please I hope you've enjoyed
everything we've done nice it was a fun
episode we have black strippers beating
off Jason Rawls Ari's bloody [ __ ]
process on the road together have fun
Road bye guys bye take care bye